foreign
[Music]
the Star Wars production team keeps
going and going most recently Andor
particularly impressed critics and soon
Ahsoka is expected to satisfy fans of
Star Wars Rebels and Clone Wars next
year the first live-action series from
the high Republic era Star Wars the
acolyte will finally be released so find
out everything that is known about this
exciting new project in this video
the acolyte takes place a long time
before the events of the Star Wars
movies the Jedi Order is at the peak of
its power here as Rangers they protect
the rim of the Republic for example from
the night Hill a group of pirates
through secret routes and hyperspace the
group always succeeds in roaming the
Galaxy unnoticed causing death and
destruction the Jedi must also confront
the dren gear an amorphous plant-like
species that seeks to consume all living
things the focus of the series however
is on the Sith at this point the Jedi
Order thinks the Sith have already been
exterminated or at least vanished deep
into the unknown regions of the Galaxy
the emphasis on the Sith is already in
the name of the series as their warriors
were known as acolytes at the time of
the Sith wars in the acolyte the
so-called order of the Sith Lords will
play a role for the first time in fact
it has been placed in Legends so it is
no longer considered part of the
official Canon however there are rumors
that the series will bring many aspects
of it back to Canon the series is
described as a mystery thriller that
primarily follows former Jedi Apprentice
Aura she encounters the Sith and soon
finds herself in the middle of a huge
conflict select on one side of the Sith
who want to use her as a tool on the
other side is her former Master Paul who
wants to bring her back to the Light
Side while we will definitely see are
plenty of lightsaber duels as director
Leslie Headland told variety the series
will be a mix of Frozen and Kill Bill
mainly using Samurai movies as general
inspiration like Quentin Tarantino what
other well-known Sith and Jedi we will
see remains unclear in any case The
Chosen setting of The High Republic
offers a lot of potential
the majority of the cast of The acolyte
is already known while it isn't clear
yet which role each of the actors will
play the cast is already looking pretty
impressive the starring role of Aura
will be played by Amanda Stenberg the
American actress was last seen in the
horror comedy body's body's bodies her
old Mentor Paul is played by Lee
jong-jae some of you may know the Korean
from the successful Netflix series squid
game
a few of the appearing Jedi are also
confirmed kalnaka marks the first time
we will see a Wookie Jedi Master in a
live-action series we already know the
Wookie Padawan gun guy from The Clone
Wars in the bad batch kalnaka will be
played by Finnish basketball player Juna
suatamo suwitama already assumed the
role of Chewbacca in episode 7 to 9 as
well as in Solo a Star Wars story
readers of the Star Wars books can look
forward to a reunion with Jedi Knight
for nestra Roe Vern as she is called by
her friend is the youngest Jedi in the
order at this time the character also
gives us a clue as to what point in time
the series is set she appeared about 232
years before the Battle of Yavin a
special characteristic of Vern is her
lightsaber which she can turn into a
whip a fact that is regarded as critical
among the Jedi the mireillon is played
by Canadian actress Rebecca Henderson
Henderson is 43 years old so we assume
that we will meet an older version of
the Jedi than previously known from the
books Dean Charles Chapman will also
play a part in the new series and we can
already see him on set pictures as Jedi
Padawan Chapman will be recognized by
most of you as king tommen from Game of
Thrones however the name of his role in
the acolyte is still unknown one of the
most recognizable names in the cast
though is without question Carrie Anne
Moss The Matrix actress was also
featured in the first images shown at
the Star Wars celebration on them she
can be spotted at a Jedi Temple in a
fight with a manly stenberg's main
character Aura here Moss is wielding a
yellow lightsaber so we can safely
assume that she is playing a Jedi who
guards the temple
moreover there will be a character named
Jackie nothing is known about her yet
and she appears in either in the books
nor in the comics of the high Republic
she will be played by Daphne Keane the
young actress made famous by her role as
Laura in Logan some known cast members
can't be attached to any roles yet Manny
Jacinto for example who last appeared in
Top Gun Maverick Jody Turner Smith is
likewise part of the cast the actors can
be seen in a black robe on the first set
pictures so it is likely that she will
be one of the Sith then there's Charlie
Barnett who we know from smaller roles
in various series and Margarita levieve
who appeared in the Sci-Fi drama future
world
the concept screenplay and direction of
the acolyte have all been entrusted to
one person Russian doll Creator Leslie
Headland the latter was already given
the task of writing a Star Wars series
with a female lead by Disney in 2020
casting began in 2021 with filming on
October 30th 2022 at shinfield studios
in the UK under the working title
Paradox just like the Star Wars series
The Mandalorian and Obi-Wan Kenobi the
acolyte will make use of stagecraft
Technology meaning it will be filmed in
front of giant LED walls there is no
first teaser or trailer yet but the
series is scheduled to come out on
Disney Plus in 2024 and will consist of
eight episodes
that was all the information we got
about Star Wars the acolyte are you
hyped as we are to finally see a Star
Wars production that centers on the Sith
which characters from The High Republic
would you love to see in the series let
us know in the comments and if you liked
the video be sure to give it a thumbs up
thanks for watching
[Music]